now the Oscar winner Alyssia vikander
she showing some major body confidence
in the new tomb raider out today Alyssia
endured some intense workouts to get
lara croft cut and i was with the
trainer who made it happen I wanted her
to be a strong physical girl so I
started to gain muscle and gain strength
how much muscle did ELISA put on I think
she gains 12 was that all muscle yeah I
know what you're thinking at about 5 5
and 117 pounds
ELISA is a tiny woman to begin with but
check out this before-and-after how'd
she get those abs and Tomb Raider v I
started 3 months before shoot to work
with Magnus Tomb Raider actually tells
the origin story of Angelina Jolie's
Lara Croft back in 2002 Angie did weight
training and Taekwondo to prepare for
the role her end result was this and you
can see alyssia's results too and let's
start all the way down so I tried out
the Magnus method at cross bootcamp
lots of intervals to burn off the fat
pull ups planks and twists for the ass
during the filming add 3 eggs and some
fruit after workout in the morning then
at 10 I had like two filets of fish a
bowl of rice and vegetables and then
similarity one at four at seven so that
like for huge meals today that's not
free in life I'm gonna I'm back on you
know I'm drinking my wine I'm eating my
food when you rapped and you said okay I
can eat again was the first thing that
you went for the veggie list actually so
each Sunday
you have cheating and I would say that
you know it was pizza or pasta it was I
I woke up on Sundays and I looked round
it's pizza day
[Music]